so of your students that create web
series or set out to create them
what do you see as their biggest
stumbling block in the beginning
uh that's an interesting question i i
think the biggest stumbling block for
them is really
understanding what a kind of a concept
you need to support
a series as opposed to a single or maybe
two or three stories
and um it's not it doesn't come as
naturally as one might think it's it's
elusive because we see so many
web series we think well it must be easy
to come up with these concepts
but it isn't and a lot of times my
students do a total of four episodes and
with the concepts that
don't really have legs you can feel it
by the time you're trying to
develop a story for episode three and
four that they're huffing and puffing
trying to come up with an idea
interesting so it sounds like then they
come up with these grand ideas but maybe
then there's not longevity
sometimes there's not longevity to the
idea sometimes
this is because they're younger writers
or they're newer writers and so they
they don't have the
experience but you know even among
professionals i remember hearing
a quip from one of the laverne and
shirley writers that they were
celebrating their 150th episode and one
of the
writers got up and to make a toast and
said well we've done 150 episodes
that's almost 75 different stories so
they knew they were repeating themselves
on a professional television series so
it's challenged to come up with a
different story every week for your
characters or every episode
you